sie stehen da nun schon wochen die
waggons mit ukrainischem sonnenblumenöl
mais und getreide und sie kommen nicht
weiter denn die osteuropäische
spurbreite der eisenbahn endet dort wo
die eu beginnt
nur in galati in rumänien gibt es beide
spurbreiten rund fünf kilometer bis zu
einem donauhafen doch jahrzehnte lang
wurde die strecke nicht genutzt
jetzt ist krieg im nachbarland jetzt
wird die strecke gebraucht denn nichts
kann raus über den ukrainischen hafen
oder
mihai ob es ankommt um es selbst zu
sehen er kann es kaum glauben in nur
zwei monaten soll die alte linie wieder
befahrbar sein erzählt er bis zu seinem
tod im hafen ein riesengeschäft für ihn
eine chance für sein land und die
ukraine
der minister war schon da und hat gesagt
ja wir machen das aber
es muss eben erst mal gemacht werden
dafür braucht es auch solches material
aus der ukraine und aus moldawien kommt
ja nicht nur getreide die haben auch
andere produkte bisher konnten sie nicht
kommen jetzt ja diese erneuerte linie
wäre also eine gute sache für die
zukunft und nicht vergeblich
in galas spürt man am meisten dass
rumänien sich ändern muss kilometerlange
lkw staus an der grenze rund 20
millionen tonnen ukrainisches getreide
müssen noch raus und die nächste ernte
rumäniens jahrelange politische
misswirtschaft rächt sich nun ob beim
transport oder der energie das
grenznaher ich konnte jetzt hat damit
erfahrungen erzählt bürgermeister georg
gebote sein dorf sei hübsch aber arm das
muss nicht sein
es hätte jährlich eine million euro
steuern einnehmen können aus windparks
die hier vor zehn jahren geplant waren
doch plötzlich strich die regierung die
förderungen die hügel blieben kahl ein
fehler wie sich jetzt zeigt sagt bothe
der krieg hat investitionen in
windenergie dringender gemacht
und die regierung verzögert die dinge
nicht länger
und so wird das dorf bald umringt sein
von windrädern niemals sei dagegen sagt
er jetzt noch weniger als früher maria
da sport zum beispiel
sie ist in diesem haus aufgewachsen die
rentnerin ärgert sich über hohe
energierechnungen erst recht wenn das
geld dafür ins ausland geht
ich weiß gar nicht warum ich letzten
monat so viel für gas bezahlt habe es
ist doch besser etwas zu verbrauchen was
wir selbst haben auf dem feld stören sie
mich nicht und tun gut es für uns
zehn jahre lang wurden in rumänien kaum
windparks errichtet gleich mehrere
werden demnächst gebaut jetzt soll alles
ganz schnell gehen auch mit
offshore-windanlagen und der
gasförderung auf dem schwarzen meer über
jahre bremsten politische rangeleien die
heimische förderung und der russische
anteile am gasverbrauch wuchs von 2 auf
20 prozent
doch der krieg verschlug den politischen
knoten seit heute fließt von hier grünes
gas ins netz die schwarzmeer gasreserven
können rumäniens bedarf für rund zehn
jahre decken und der alten pracht der
hafenstadt constanta zu neuem glanz
verhelfen
die renovierung des casinos habe er noch
als präfekt auf den weg gebracht erzählt
mir georgen niculescu jetzt ist der
staatssekretär im energieministerium
niculescu ist hier ein neuer
ungewöhnlicher politikertyp dem
energieexperten geht es eher um die
sache als um die macht
300 kilometer weiter ist krieg das ist
schrecklich aber auch eine
bewährungsprobe für sein land und seine
stadt
ich bin mir sicher rumänien kann in
dieser region sehr wichtig für die
energieversorgung werden
auch im export für alle nachbarländer
mit denen uns pipelines verbinden
rumänien als retter in der krise
das land kämpft auch mit sich selbst
viele zufahrten zum hafen sind blockiert
die staatsbahn stellt hier seit jahren
ihren schrott ab
doch für die alte misswirtschaft und
korruption rumäniens ist nun keine zeit
mehr meint viorel panait denn vor dem
hafen warten frachtschiffe aufladung die
sie sonst aus odessa bekommen
jetzt laden sie hier getreide für afrika
im schnellsten terminal europa zieht mir
stolz erklärt und bald ist es noch
schneller
drei tage nach kriegsbeginn haben wir
verstanden der bedarf steigt
wir haben vier millionen euro investiert
und sind ende des monats fertig
[Musik]
dann werden hier doppelt so schnell
fluss bargen entladen und frachtschiffe
beladen tempo ist gefragt bei allen
transporten die kapazität könnt ihr hier
in kurzer zeit um 50 prozent gesteigert
werden meint borel wenn eu und regierung
das wollen und fördern und sich auch in
den köpfen was ändert brl will dass es
so kommt
dieses soll monschauer der krieg ist wie
eine kalte dusche
und kalte duschen können uns alle
aufwecken und das dauerhaft denn es ist
einfach notwendig
22 frachtschiffe warten vor konstanzer
so viele wie selten in drei wochen
beginnt die neue ernte in rumänien
entscheidet sich der wettlauf mit der
zeit